an Ohio abortion clinic is encouraging
people to get abortions on the grounds
that it's a good parenting decision the
clinic preterm has started a campaign
called my abortion my life they set up
16 billboards around Cleveland they
extol the death of unborn children with
phrases like abortion is necessary
abortion is your right and in one case
abortion is a parenting decision
meanwhile at UC San Francisco
purportedly still at college a
sociologist is calling on TV shows to
include more abortion related comedy in
order to normalize the procedure dr.
Robin Bremen is a psychologist and she
agrees the billboards and the comedy she
joins us today dr. Bryant thanks coming
on thank you so abortion comedy what
what would you say is the funny part
about abortion I don't think they're
using it as a funny thing I think
they're using it just to bring out the
the to make it more of a real thing or
more of a huh that's why I came here
okay okay
can you hear me doctor one sec I don't
think they're using it as a cut for
comedy I think they're trying to
distinguish a what why do you think if
that sounds probably right what why do
you think there's a stigma around
abortion well I think there's in the
world there's there's so much stigma
around it I mean it's a very hard
decision to make for a woman it's a
no-win situation if you what why the
stigma why is it considered bad do you
think why is it considered a stigma yeah
well because it's ending a life for some
people huh okay so if you think it but
if you don't think it's ending a life
then there shouldn't be any stigma at
all right well it's not it's not one way
or the other I think it's a traumatic
thing that women could go through I
think it's in a way it's absolutely
ending a life and another way it's you
put it in a no-win situation because
sometimes people have no other choice
okay so but then why would you I mean
all of that I mean you're probably the
mainstream of views on that then why the
impulse to make light of ITER's you said
do you Sigma ties it in comedy or put up
billboards encouraging people to have
abortions isn't that making light of it
isn't that minimizing it what as you
said it's a very serious thing I
honestly don't think it's making light
of it I think it's just bringing out the
issue of abortion that it's an option
well is there anything about abortion
that makes you you personally
uncomfortable absolutely I mean it's a
very hard thing for women to go through
I think it's an absolute no-win
situation for what is it what does that
mean no-win situation other words it
means that a woman that has an unwanted
pregnancy has to make a decision and the
decision is a no-win situation she has
to end the life of an unborn baby I mean
I think you're right so why do you hear
people say you know we should celebrate
it we should convince others there's
nothing wrong with it it's not a big
deal it's a positive thing oh it's not
it's a huge deal and it's not a positive
thing and I don't agree with that I
think it's a traumatic thing that
sometimes there's no other option and
that's why I do can keep saying it's a
no-win situation because it really is
but I never hear I mean I guess I
disagree with your last point about
there's no other option but I respect
you for saying that it's a that it is a
big deal but I keep hearing a Planned
Parenthood leaders for example say you
should wear a t-shirt announcing it and
that this it's a form of liberation and
not acknowledging that it's a that
there's a downside well that's that's
their opinion I can't speak for other
people but personally I see so much
trauma around it in my office and it's a
hard decision but on the other hand it's
a hard decision to keep a baby that a
mother doesn't or can't take care of
psychologically or physically ya know
it's a tough it's a tough situation and
I'm and I think it's a first step to
acknowledge that and so I'm glad that
you I'm glad that you are thank you dr.
Ryan for joining us tonight thank you
for having me thank you